When the soccer World Cup kicks off this Thursday,
imagine watching it as 3D "holograms"
on your kitchen table.
That may not be far off thanks to a new technique
that turns YouTube videos
into 3D reconstructions of matches.
The key to the approach
is a convolutional neural network –
a type of artificial intelligence algorithm
loosely modelled on the part of the brain
that processes visual data – that
researchers trained to estimate how far the
surfaces of each player are from the camera
that recorded the match.
The network analyzed 12,000 2D images of players
extracted from the soccer video game FIFA
alongside the corresponding 3D data from the game engine
to learn how the two correlate.
That allowed it to estimate depth maps for
players from unseen 2D images.
When shown unseen videos, the system accurately
predicted depth maps for each player and combined
them with the color footage to reconstruct
each player in 3D.
The players were then superimposed on a virtual
soccer pitch allowing the match to be viewed
in any 3D content viewer.
The researchers tested the approach with Microsoft’s
HoloLens smart glasses, which let them overlay
the 3D reconstruction onto a real-world tabletop.
The end product is still glitchy,
it can't recreate the ball, doesn’t work in realtime,
and only permits watching
from the side of the pitch the video was recorded.
But the technique could be more scalable
than leading approaches for reconstructing sport in 3D,
which require arrays of cameras
around the pitch recording every angle.
The researchers say the approach should also
work for other events that happen in predefined arenas
like music concerts or theatre.